[Music]
yeah so this is going to be
kind of an intro to shiny with some r
markdown
and stuff mixed in there um but first
you've already heard
a bit about prokagya i want to introduce
myself i'm mike garcia
i'm a data scientist with brokage
you know as you've heard we're an end
data science company everything from
you know talking about you know advisory
regulatory compliance kind of the
planning aspect
aspect to data engineering and then
through to you know reporting
doing the data science and analytics
that then informs the entire process and
kind of thing that is a loop that goes
back
uh kind of where i follow is more on
these last two doing
visualizations running models figuring
out how to use the data to answer
you know a particular business or
science question
um and that's going to be kind of con
the uh
focus of the workshop today is you know
using particularly shiny
for that visualization and turning your
r code into
something interactive that your end user
can engage with
uh so some quick overview quick overview
and some expectations
the workshop goal is to understand first
off
what shiny is the basics of
how you structure a shiny application
and then
how to make your own shiny app and if we
have time we're going to show
i will show you how to incorporate uh
shiny into
some some dashboards with the flex
dashboard package
um assumptions not a lot on the r
background just some general familiarity
will be helpful if you know like what
function is how to load it call it
data sets and packages um absolutely no
prior experience in
shiny or any kind of web technologies is
assumed at all
we're going to use you know chinese
heavily visual so we're going to use
ggplot for visualization if you haven't
used it before
that's fine um but some and i'll cover a
little bit of this in kind of our first
warm-up module
but of course you know if you tend to
use base r for plotting you can
absolutely incorporate base r plots into
shiny
uh kind of our general structure that
i'll try to
hold to is you know this quick intro
a quick warm-up to kind of show you some
you know get you refreshed on ggplot if
that's if that's
new to you um we're gonna kind of build
up a shiny app in
layers then we're gonna go to a bit
fancier app with some more complex
features
and then we'll do a demo at the end with
the flex dashboard package
so first off what is shiny
by definition is you know it's a
framework that allows our users
to create interactive web apps without
knowing anything about web design
so you don't really have to think about
all the underlying web technologies you
just
use r and it's kind of similar to
learning a new r package
um okay i lied there a little bit you
don't really need to know basic web
design but just a few basic things
is helpful so here's the one slide that
i'm going to
talk about web design as i said it
abstracts away the underlying
technologies of modern web design
which are three of them there's html
which um
sure sounds probably sounds pretty
familiar if you haven't worked with it
before it's essentially the building
block of a web page
and your web browser interprets it and
shows you the nice reformatted websites
that we're all used to
there's css or cascading style sheets
and this separates the content that's in
the html you know what
your web app is doing or what your
website is doing
with how it looks so you can control
those independently you can change the
content or you can
update the theme um
but they're not tied together they're
independent and then finally there's
javascript which is
scripting language that enables the
interactivity
within a web page or a web app and
typically this is executed in the user's
browser rather than on any central
server
and the idea with shiny is that it takes
all of this
and wraps it up into an easy to use
interface and framework
so for the workshop today we're going to
be using rstudio cloud
you should have received an invite to
the workspace
and been able to open up your own
session that's essentially a clone or
derivative of this project here
if you haven't put a question into the
chat
and uh one of our tas can uh can help
you
sort that out and just as a note to kind
of throughout the uh
the entire workshop if you have
questions you know pop them into the
chat either ta
get back to you i'll try to pop in and
monitor it from time to time to
see if there's things that you know
would be good to talk about
overall and yeah i'll keep this as
interactive as possible
so first thing we're going to do is
start with the warm up
actually i'm going to check in really
quick just to make sure that people are
generally able to uh to access this
if you're having problems uh accessing
any of this material
if you could throw that in the chat now
um just so i don't continue on if uh
if most people are not able to follow
along
yes i'm not sure if we can see the chat
um so it's a little tricky but i do have
a link to share uh to the actual our
studio cloud space
um i we did invite uh most of the people
that registered ahead of the workshop
today so you
should have got an email that gives you
a link to the to the project
um but if you didn't see that we have a
general link that is open that should
take you directly into the
into the space and i can drop a link to
that
in the chat for everyone to see um let
me just
pull that up and i will put that in the
chat
okay uh just give me two seconds and i i
think most people were able to i saw
that there were like over a hundred
uh people had created their own project
for this so
i think we should be good to go but i
just wanted to clarify first
um all right so yeah start out in this
so from the main folder click on the
warm up i'll go
warm up rmd so this rmd is an r markdown
document i won't go into a lot of the
details of what our markdown
specifically is
but it's essentially a way to enter you
know integrate
your code with text
in a literate programming paradigm and
then there's
you know a lot of other features that
will add in for interactivity with
either
visualizations and then ultimately shiny
so we can kind of go through this in
just like a notebook
sort of format and uh
a few lines at a time
load some packages uh this is a flex
dashboard package that we'll eventually
use
this open fda is just
a package that interfaces with the open
fda
api to get some data now you don't
really need to know the specifics about
that
but fun to play around with if you
haven't seen it before
and then just some tivers packages for
manipulation
and plotting and then the gg themes box
package as well
uh so we'll start out with uh just this
is a
helper function to gather some data from
that uh
open fda api so we're gonna grab
uh it's gonna be a function of gender
brand name uh so this will be the drug
brand name
and uh age and uh
yeah this goes through and submits a
query does some filtering on
you know those those variables brand
gender and age
uh it says that we you know want a total
count
we're going to limit it to the top 10
and then we're going to submit the query
um and then this just does some
formatting for to give the age that we
want
or to to put age in the correct format
cool so now let's actually get to doing
something so we're going to start with
uh stroke keytrada
and i think there might be better ways
to do this parameterize reports etc
and that's exactly right we're going to
build up to that so right now we're just
going to say we're going to hard code it
we're going to say we're looking at
etruda and we're going to look
specifically at
20 to 65.
you see that create function just
creates it puts it in the format that
is required by the the api
we're going to run that get adverse
function
i'm going to combine the data
so remember r bind is stacking uh the
data so it's row bind
and if you want to take a quick look at
what that looks like
use view
and here we have a term column looking
these are adverse events
the number you know total count and the
gender
cool so we've got some data let's uh
move ahead and start plotting that
so you're going to cover just
not really going to focus on you know
teaching the tidy verse teaching ggplot
but i'm just going to go over a few
kind of key things to either refresh
your memory
or if you're if you're new to this the
the key things to
to follow along so you see we start with
a data set
and we're just going to read you can
read this code just you know
one line at a time thinking of it as you
know we're just starting with the data
set and then
we're doing group by and then we're
summarizing etc
uh this operator here is the pipe
uh so we're gonna it'll link things
together you know
starting with the data set and then
we're gonna apply this next function
uh to adverse and then we're gonna apply
summarize
to the summarize the results of these
two together
and and so on
you can see we're grouping by term which
is that uh
adverse event and we're going to
summarize when you get the total count
within adverse event and then we're
going to move on and start building up
the layers of our plot
so you know gg plot stands for the
grammar of graphics it's this layered
kind of philosophy to how how to build
up a visualization
so you start out with just kind of empty
gg plot object
and we're going to add in a bar chart
we're going to tell it that we want
um we're doing something a little
fancier to
to make the ordering how we want it but
we're going to
tell it to put this on the x-axis the
count on the y-axis
um we're going to flip the coordinate at
the coordinates around so instead of
vertical bars it's going to be
horizontal
we're going to give it some labels apply
a minimal theme
and we just you know keep adding these
on top of each other
so we can do all of this in one pipeline
and we get our graphic uh
cool so but you know that's just static
you know we're going to learn how to
make this
interactive and visual
okay so yeah let's maybe take this one
step further
and do it by gender so this is pretty
much the same code but we've added one
new line here
and that's the facet wrap so instead of
repeating copy and pasting all this over
again and doing it again
you know filtering to mail and just
filtering to female
we can have the facet wrap
and we're also telling it to fill the
bars or you know do a color by gender
so we've got you know female on the left
here male
on the right and showing the
distribution of adverse events
so that's pretty much the what you
really need to know about ggplot just
think of it as you know you're building
up all of these layers we're going to
have you know different plots
using different geoms for different
graphics a few few things but you won't
really need to write any of that
code yourself if you don't if you're if
you're new to 2g plot and you're kind of
learning
that alongside shiny
of course this whole thing is a
our markdown document so i've kind of
gone through it as a notebook
but you can hit knit
and uh
you can see it as a as an html
all right so now that we're
a little bit warmed up um let's go in
and actually talk about shiny now that's
what
we said we were going to talk about so
let's dive in um
this first so i've got a series of
templates here
and they just progressively build up the
to
a working shiny app so this first one
is the absolute minimum minimal shiny
app
that you can have and it has four
components
first off you you know you have to call
the library you have call shiny so
library shiny
you have this fluid page function which
is empty you know there's no arguments
in it yet
and we're assigning the output of that
function to this u
and you're giving it the name ui and
similarly we've got this server which is
a function that we're defining and it
takes three inputs you know input output
session the names of the arguments
and then it's just currently just an
empty function
and then finally we're calling this
shiny app on the ui and the server
so this is a fully working shiny app but
that's really boring and so one thing
you can do here
if you click on next to run app
if you run in window it'll pop up a new
window run external
it'll pop up in a browser window you can
also select view or pane and i'm going
to do that just for presentation ease
hide the environment and now it'll show
up in this viewer pane here
so i can run that and yep it doesn't it
says says you know it's listening on
this
uh you know local host on this port
and you know it's busy it's doing
something look over the viewers just
empty
uh of course it's empty because we
haven't actually done anything yet
let's go ahead and stop that so i'll
talk a little bit about just the purpose
of these different components
and then we'll actually start putting in
some content to
just solidify we know what what those
these different things are doing
so the ui is where we're going to put
everything related to
what you might think of as like the
design or the look and feel of the app
so you know different buttons and
sliders and ways of input
kind of the overall layout structure of
the app is going to go right there
the server is where most of your r code
is going to go
that's going to be you know the code
that's generating the plots that's maybe
filtering
according to some drop down menu that's
selected
and then shiny app is actually what's
running the app so if you
don't have that last line this
you know your your app won't run there's
a quick note too kind of a
helpful tip that you know it's often
easy it's often useful when you're
either building a complex app to kind of
you know just build like a little
component of it by itself or maybe
you're going through some exercises and
you get really tired of like copying
this boilerplate over and over again
our studio has something called a
snippet that's built in
if you just type in shiny and you'll see
the shiny app snippet that pops up
that'll actually just populate
your uh
your uh code your your menu with uh
with that boilerplate so that's a quick
way if you just want to test what you
know like what a particular input or
something does
uh
well so we'll stop that app and open up
the next one so this one
um point out we haven't changed anything
in the lower bit so we still have this
you know
empty server and the shiny app um
what we've modified now is we've added
something to the ui
so this is kind of where we start to
think about what do we want the app to
look like
um when you're actually doing this in
practice for something more complicated
it's often helpful to sit down with a
pen and paper and actually sketch out
what you want it to look like you know
which components which visualizations do
you want in which areas
and it can get a little overwhelming if
you try to
start building it up or a little complex
if you don't have a good vision
of what you want it to look like uh so
we've got some things like a
title this thing called sidebar layout
a couple panels let's just run this and
see what it looks like
cool so we've got some material here
we've got
you know our title is going up here this
is kind of interesting you might we see
the sidebar
layout and we've specified position left
although it's kind of in the center and
um
you know we've got it within that
sidebar layout you can see that
function comprises like lines eight
through 16.
you know we've got two two panels within
one for the inputs and one for the main
results they're all kind of stacked on
top of each other
um so i'm going to give
you a moment or two to kind of play
around with this i've got a couple
exercises at the bottom um yeah moving
just try moving the sidebar to the right
maybe play around with the order of this
just kind of play around for you know
a minute or so and and get a feel um
for this and if uh kind of curious does
any if anyone has any ideas of why
this might be uh
just stacked and not why it's not
actually putting it on the left
and are we actually able to see the uh
the chat the questions um unfortunately
not i don't think for some reason it's
based on operating system
so far though i've seen questions for
getting the link um let's see let me
look in and see if there's any other
questions in here that we can that you
might be able to answer
um besides getting the link um
let's see and we've got one question
saying are you going to be covering
shiny modules
in today's presentation uh good question
unfortunately there's i don't think
there's enough to go time to go from
absolute intro to shiny all the way to
shiny modules
um in a 90-minute workshop i wish i
could um
so if yeah anyone's curious about what
that is it's just a way of kind of
breaking up your codes you're getting
less repetitive you might have like a
particular
interface and it would drop down this
you know drop down menu that creates
this visualization
and you want to incorporate that into
either different parts of your app
or different apps entirely you can kind
of modularize your code and if you're uh
you've written a lot of code you're
probably used to doing that you know you
write a function to do
something rather than copying and
pasting the same thing over again
so there's shiny modules help address
that
but yeah we won't have time to get to
that unfortunately
awesome thank you mike i am i'm seeing
if there's any
other questions um and are you going to
be covering uh interactive plots in
shiny today
yes that will definitely in fact we'll
we're on
part two out of five here and by the
time we get to five we will have
a basic interactive plot
excellent perfect and so those are all
the questions that i can see coming in
right now
so if you want to keep on going and at
any point if you'd like to pause and i
can read out some questions as well
sounds great um yeah so
yeah let's just kind of go through this
and say let's move this to the right and
see what happens
kind of unsurprisingly it looks the same
as if it was on the left and
you know it was centered wise on the
right
now maybe you're opening this in a
different window or in a browser and you
may have seen something entirely
differently
the reason for this is that
the shiny recognizes what size screen
you're looking at
so it's looking at just this kind of you
know right portion of my screen
and it is viewing that because it's
small it's kind of viewing that almost
like
a mobile device or a tablet
and if it placed it on the left it would
get everything would be really scrunched
except for
you know especially when you have a
visualization in there but unless if i
drag this out far enough okay now it's
at some point here it
decides okay that's a big enough screen
um
and it lets me do what i want to but
instead of having to like
you know specify a different interface
for a mobile device and a tablet and
like maybe a small like surface pro and
then a huge
desktop it just you know it
it's smart and it says okay you probably
actually don't want you know your full
interface here
i'm just going to stack them because
that's going to look better
but yeah you can see now that's on the
right if you
it's on the left you can hit reload the
app so you don't have to actually stop
and
reload but now okay now our inputs are
on the left
cool so that's all you know the
interface we haven't really done
anything
to make it interactive at all yet it's
still just
you know a static document essentially
uh so let's build this up a little bit
let's you know we still have this you
know
you can see now it's getting more
complicated but this is still a pretty
simple app
and this is why it's a good idea to
sketch things out in advance
rather than just starting to put things
in and having it snowball on you
you know end up with a lot of spaghetti
code so we still got our
title still got our sidebar layout
and now instead of you know we've got
our panel
sidebar panel and a main panel and
within those so these you used to just
have some
a little bit of text now we've got a new
kind of suite of functions
and these input functions are kind of
one of the keys to understanding shiny
these are the things that make these are
the input side of the reactive
aspect of of shiny so we've got
two inputs that we're putting in and
you'll see a lot of different sorts of
inputs
like radio buttons drop down sliders
and they all have like some sort of
descriptor and then
input and all of them start with
an id this id is key this is how
you're going to how the rest of your
code when we start actually writing
the server side code is going to
recognize these different inputs
and we'll give it a label which is
you know human friendly make sure you
know so we can read it
and then there's a you know different
choice different val or
different arguments depending on the
inputs and this particular one we're
looking at
this is a drop down and we're giving it
these choices we say
you can choose either 70 75 85 or 90.
here we've got a slider input so you'll
see those first two arguments are the
same
in fact a lot of times you won't even
see people you know
specify the name you'll just say slider
input bins
common number of bins but now since we
have a slider we need to give it
a range the minimum value it can take
the maximum value it can take
and the default value
uh so that's all in the sidebar
and in the main panel uh we're still not
up to full interactivity where we have
uh where you know you're
changing the inputs and you're getting a
visualization that's changing
but i'll just show you a couple things
that you can you know you can embed
a local image if you want to you know
put something in
or you can these vrs if you do know a
little html you might
realize okay that's like the br tag
that's just an easy way to
um to put that in
right into your but you know inject some
basic html right into your uh
into your app so stop our previously
running one
and hit run app
and cool so it's you know getting a
little bit more
like something we want we've got some
interac you know at least what feels
like interactive but we can interact
with it
you know pick different numbers move our
slider around
um we actually have something to look at
over here
but it's still there's nothing connect
there's no logic in the back end there's
no
we're not you know running a
visualization we're not generating a
table
and we're definitely not connecting
anything that we're doing here to
you know our code that's running to put
results over here
so finally let's get on to talking about
the server
and switching it up a little bit here
and introducing some data to play around
with this is
the his data package and this is just uh
cholera data from the um
london cholera epidemic of the 19th
century jon snow
and we're moving changing things a
little bit here to accommodate that data
but not
really we still have our slider input we
may have changed the range a little bit
there
but now we've got something a little bit
different in the main panel
before we have we're just loading out
our studio
logo and a little bit of text uh now
you can say like we have the the inputs
up here
uh now we've got outputs uh so anything
you know any if you think about your
whole app is
you know the user specifying input and
the app
taking that input and returning a specif
you know showing a specific
you know combination of visualizations
and tables and you know a certain output
corresponding to that input this is
where all of your outputs go
all of your outputs get wrapped in these
output functions
so there's you know plot output there's
one corresponding ones for tables
for text if you want to dynamically
render our markdown
there's there's an output for that and
similar to you know you have this input
id for each of your inputs
all of your output ids have an output id
now hopefully you're starting to just
see that you've got all of these
different
um you know ids and components
and really if you have that sketch laid
out you can
you know label them with this is the id
for that this is the idea for that and
just
makes things a lot cleaner to uh as
you're building this up if you have that
kind of map in your you know rough
sketch already you know laid out ahead
of time
and finally we have some server
logic that uh you know this was empty
until now
and emphasize that most this is mostly
um just
our code so we're going to ignore most
of it for the moment
or you know ignore these you know render
plots and stuff for the moment
and
no worries reconnected and uh yeah
actually didn't lose anything great
um
yeah so this is all just our code right
here
um like you know so you call it ggplot
we're forgiving the data set we're
giving it the x val value we're telling
it to you know
fill we're telling you to do a histogram
down here we're making a box plot
um and
that's great and all and what we're
doing here is now we're starting to use
those labels
we're saying that yeah we're creating
this you know this
plot but we're going to put it in
this you know this histogram we're going
to put that in
the uh this output id so we've kind of
created a space in our user interface
for the histogram and we're going to say
okay we're going to put this
there and we wrap it in this render plot
so that ultimately when our inputs
change this listens to those inputs and
will update it only when so it's not
only when the inputs change it's not
continually
redoing if you change one component it's
not redoing your entire app it's just
loading you know the part
that's you know recomputing the part
that needs to be computed
similarly for the box plot
so let's run this see what it looks like
and cool we have something that actually
looks like a useful shiny app we've got
our slider we've got two plots here
but there's one thing missing and
you know see if we're changing the
number of bins
um you know id you know obviously
we want the number of bins in our
histogram to change and it's not doing
that
and the reason why it's not doing that
is i'm just telling it to take the
entire data set
compute the histogram throw it in here
there's nothing tying it back to the
number of bins that i have
and i could add that as an argument here
um
but if i specify say like number of
bands equals 10 or if
20 whatever then that's still hard
coding in i need it
need it to listen to the to the input
so finally let's open up this last one
um this is pretty similar but
i've added in this is kind of more just
for you to play around with
on your own time if you want just a
different way of structuring it
so you see instead of having just a
sidebar layout
i've kind of got that nested within this
tab set panel
so it's just a different way of
organizing uh your app
giving you know if you have a lot of
components you kind of want to break
these across different pages to make it
a little bit easier to navigate
but the main thing that we want to focus
on is here
where now we have you know we have a
histogram and now we change it to a
scatter plot
but instead of just
you know filtering you know putting in
the entire data set we're filtering it
into
the specific input that we've created so
you can see that water input
scroll up
right here under this radio button input
we have an id called water input so
anytime that radio button
is changed you know a different one is
selected that's gonna
you know this this function here is
listening for that change
and when it changes it's going to rerun
this bit of code
with that value of water input so
if you're going for you know you're just
playing around with a data set you build
up some cool plots
you can often just stick your code
existing code directly
in to your server function you know wrap
it and render
plot and usually just need to change a
few
you know one or maybe sometimes more
inputs to
instead of you know instead of doing it
by water input
you know you just have to prefix it with
input dollar sign
and you'll see over here in our original
code too there's you know the input now
instead of
just g on histogram we're showing the uh
listening to that bin count variable
so now i can move this and it's doing
what we expect
yeah so just a few bins a lot of bins
now it's broken up instead of having you
know another plot underneath here
and select okay you know want to look at
scatter plot
and we want to you know look at the
scatter plots
of a number of houses by death rate we
want to do this separately for each
water source
now here this is where i'm selecting
like new river now i'm selecting
q and that water input id is changing
and this is re running so and then it's
outputting it to the output object
named scatterplot which we've selected
here
and that's the core logic within shiny
you have inputs that have ids
when those change the
server functions that listen for them
recognize that change
recompute the visualization based on
that change and then output it
into the slots that you've specified you
know these outputs
with the corresponding id
um
cool so that concludes uh this module
kind of building up the logic everything
from this point
on is going to be kind of playing around
with different ways of
laying things out maybe a little bit
more complex apps some more
interactivity so
check in here and see if there are any
questions
yeah mike let me quickly take a look and
see what are some questions that we've
got
that you can quickly discuss let's see
[Music]
um yeah here's one so do you have any
tips for
naming ids um they say they think this
becomes important for more complex shiny
apps when there are many
identical widgets i.e many text inputs
yeah definitely and i think that's kind
of one of the areas that can really
snowball quickly especially if you
you're just playing around with the data
set and you make a couple of you know
cool plots and you're like oh let me
turn this into a shiny shiny
uh app and you know you create a simple
shiny app and you're like oh but it
would be cool if it did this and it
would do this and then pretty soon it
can be it can be pretty easy to have you
know some
monster with a bunch of different inputs
that are interacting in really complex
ways
and uh again that's why i just kind of
like stepping back and have it like once
it
and that's totally fine you know for
interactive um
you know just building things up
prototyping but at some point you kind
of have to step back and be like well
this is
getting more complicated take a step
back
kind of refactor it out have a better
layout try to identify you know are you
how do you have redundant inputs that
you know can
some be combined um and then
sit back and like you know take a few
minutes to like make that sketch
think about how the different parts are
interacting
and then if you really truly do have
like identical code like maybe say we
were just
creating like the same like histogram
over and over again but
um it was just getting replicated in a
lot of you know essentially the same
code was getting replicated in a lot of
different
um parts then
um the what was
earlier question about shiny modules
that would uh that would be a solution
to that
cool thank you and then i have i see one
other question coming in here
um which would be a good one to discuss
is what are some good ways for hosting
shiny apps for example can it be hosted
on github
um what are some recommended services
that you would say for hosting shiny
yeah another great question i'm going to
cover this a little bit in the wrap up
too
but there's yeah a few different options
ultimately
shiny apps are just web apps and they
can be run on any server
so right now i'm just running that
locally well it's on our studio cloud
but it's just
using that cloud server as a local
server
you can do the same thing on like our
studio in your desktop browser the
obvious limitation is that
you can't share it with anyone or to
share you have to send your code they
have to
have all the you know rr studio all the
right packages installed they have to
you know run it there's
some easy ways with shinyapps.io
and then there's also the within our
studio enterprise
suite of software there's rstudio
connect that allows you to
essentially i'm not don't believe i'm
connected to a connect server right now
but you can publish
a shiny app just right from our studio
and then if you have time for one more
um one more question cool um i have a
couple more but uh it's all you know
however many questions you want to take
right now right um
another one is how do you parameterize
shiny apps for example if you wanted to
run the same report but for different
segments
is it easy to do this how would you do
that
that is a good question um
in some sense shiny is kind of taking
care of the parameterization because it
allows you to select different values
but yeah safer you wanted the same plot
and you want or the same app but you
only wanted it limited to
a particular year a particular data set
particular time frame
um actually might bounce this to
fill if you're there yeah i'm here i'm
here i just yeah
i'm not sure if i'm able to um submit
through the chat box as a
as the person overseeing it so i sent
the link to samantha
and um there's a couple different ways
to dive into this question
i think how i would tackle it is
integrating our markdown with shiny
and so really what you end up doing is
using our markdown as the report
template or the report engine for your
shiny app
and so in the example that i just sent
samantha
what it lets you do is basically use the
chat
oh okay it's in the chat fantastic so
basically you can use the option and
shiny there within this
application that i'm uh i shared through
the
chat box and it will let you pick
different variables or different parts
of the data that you have
and then what it will do is uh
dynamically and reactively change the
visualization
and then for that state you can actually
use our markdown
in the server folder to act
or excuse me in the shiny apps folder to
actually use our markdown to
generate reports so this is a nice
example of how you can use our markdown
as kind of the behind the scenes report
engine
and gives you that capability of
generating reports um directly from your
shiny app
um and it's another reason why in the
workshops i teach sometimes i'll
i'll really try hard to make sure people
understand the connection between our
markdown and shiny
not only because you can turn our
markdown reports into shiny apps
but because of this other uh way to
approach reports via shiny apps and
using our markdown
so
yeah so that's that's probably how i
would tackle it but there um there's
definitely other ways to go about this
um and so yeah but but that one's pretty
simple and a nice clean example
to work from cool
awesome yeah thanks phil and uh yeah and
actually
we'll have an example on that um that
format of you know turning uh
our markdown document embedding shiny
into it at the uh
at the end of the workshop yeah yeah i
guess
uh you know i think i saw one other
question i can answer really quickly
about using custom plotting code and the
answer is yes
um you know we're using kind of building
up our own custom gg plot here
if you wanted to use say base r or a
different
you know entirely you know different
library for visualization
you could put that code in here it's
just whatever
output that that you know judy plot base
r
plotly whatever puts out is going to
get passed through an appropriate render
function
that'll then place that output in the
right spot of your of your app
so absolutely you can create uh that's
yeah because the entire idea behind
you can create your own custom
visualizations
and you know of course make them
reactive and dynamic
cool so um i saw a few more questions
come in but
mike how are you feeling about time um
should we go ahead and maybe take a five
minute break
um do you want to keep on keep on
chugging through do you want to do some
questions
um it's what what do you feel like doing
right now
all right cool um yeah maybe now would
be
a good time for a break and then uh like
i said we've kind of at this point we've
covered the
core concepts um and then from now on
it's just kind of
making it you know cooler layouts more
complex
interactivity that sort of thing um so
yeah let's take five minutes now
perfect we'll take a five-minute break
and then let's join again
at um it's 2 53 right now
so let's go ahead and join at 3 o'clock
um but we'll probably have to be
wrapping up probably around 3 30 at the
very latest
sounds great all right sounds good so um
with that then i'm going to hand it over
to kevin
um if kevin you want to just go through
and show that video again or maybe do
any overview on prakagya
and we will give mike a break
thanks samantha
and i will go ahead and share my
screen again and i might actually
instead of just playing the slide
silently
uh if there's anybody who's hanging
around during the break
i can walk his true slides
so again uh thanks to everybody for
sticking around for this pharmax session
um as part of the rstudio global event
i hope everybody's signed up for
different
uh seminars and presentations throughout
the global event it should be
pretty interesting and uh really excited
to see how it's panned out and
i hope when things are back to normal we
retain some sort of
global element to to this conference
because i think it really provides a
a really good opportunity to be a bit
more inclusive of people around the
world
who can't make it to the physical event
but with that being said uh i just want
to give a quick
talk through of procorgia for anybody
who's still around
and again these slides were flashing
around earlier but just to reiterate
what
mike had said at the start of his
presentation uh how we're an end-to-end
data solutions provider
so again we mainly concentrate on
the data space so if it has nothing to
do with data that's that's really where
we're interested
in having an impact and so we started
off
as a consulting firm focusing on data
science
and making an impact there but we
quickly realized that
in order to provide true value to your
customers you gotta
really be involved from the start to the
end there's just
too many important moving parts uh from
the start to beginning so
from that advisory stage where you're
talking about planning out what your
architecture is going to be
a lot of companies moving from
on-premise infrastructure to on cloud
infrastructure
or maybe just moving from excel sheets
to databases and
whatever stage of the data journey
they're at
we like to meet with clients figure out
where they're at and where they would
like to get
to and help them architect that solution
and we've started to help them then
actually setting up
that infrastructure through our
engineering practice
and then where it gets really
interesting and fun is uh where a lot of
things i think of the people in this
conference in our studio conference and
final conference they're interested in
and that's around the business
intelligence and data science and
analytics and that's
you know where we have a lot of people
who work for us then with a lot of
knowledge in the open source
uh data science tool sets so a lot of
our users in our company
python and we like to
help our customers gain insights through
dashboard development
and whether it be through rstudio or
other platforms like you see power bi
there as well
is a very popular one these days and uh
yeah as mike is walking us through here
on the shiny apps and
a lot of our organizations especially in
the farm industry love to use shiny and
i can't blame them because it's a
fantastic tool uh
really allows a lot of flexibility and
um it's my tool choice if i if i had the
choice of which
tool to use it's the one i always tend
to gravitate towards
then of course uh you know the more data
science and more advanced analytics
uh that you can get to do where you can
start coming up with some predictive and
uh even prescriptive analytics where you
know we're not just uh
telling you where your data is going but
we can help you figure out
what to change in order to gain the kind
of outcomes that you desire
inside of your business operation very
popular i think in the manufacturing
setting now is they start to get into
machine automation and stuff like that
and i think that's where prescriptive
analytics is going to have
a big impact and that obviously impacts
the farm industry
with respect to their manufacturing
processes etc
so yeah a lot of a lot of really
exciting things going on data science
analytics and uh
specifically with prescriptive analytics
and when that starts to really take hold
i think we'll see some
really amazing innovations in uh in
pharmaceuticals
so just some of the areas that you can
get in touch with pekogia and you know
using data science machine learning to
help improve patient care
uh help improve effectiveness of drug
trials
become more targeted in your sales
marketing and of course
accelerating drug discovery and
development which is a very
popular use case for artificial
intelligence
in the farm industry right now using the
likes of neural networks etc to
really gain the power of data science
and uh high compute power to
come up with some really cool
innovations in the drug space
and this is just a quick overview again
of uh
the general approach that we'd like to
take at picogia so similar to that
first slide i showed where we go end to
end so it's all about figuring out where
your business is at
and where it wants to go to and after
we've done that we've kind of assessed
what kind of needs you have
starting to put in the plan in place to
move your company towards a more
data-driven approach
and uh through our approach and
partnership
we're able to drive some actionable
insight there
this is just a sample of some of our
previous clients existing clients and
key partners that we work with so our
studio being
the main one on showcase today we love
working with those guys and
helping evangelize for the r studio and
team suite um which we believe is one of
the most powerful
uh integrated environments for analytics
and data science
out there and we do a lot of work uh
helping deploy that on cloud so whether
that be
aws or azure um we
we think that this is the way forward
for for our studio deployments
and really helping help life science
partners move
to the cloud securely is a big focus for
us
cool and it looks like with that um we
are exactly at the top of the hour
um uh why don't we kevin go ahead and
i'll hand it over to
mike who's going to uh take
us on our final sections with shiny
um for the last 30 minutes of today's
workshop
so mike i'm going to make you the
presenter
and it's great to have you back
cool i think uh enjoying my screen
a little bit smoother than last time it
looks like it's the mastering shiny
screen right now yes
exactly um so i saw one question
about downloads and none of this is
built into the
uh the material on the webinar but i
just want to quickly say that yes you
can
upload and download and this is kind of
the go-to reference book
mastering shiny and it essentially works
by
um you know there's a instead of
within your interface you specify like
download buttons and links
those get connected to actions so that
when you click on them it triggers
in this case write csv
to a specific location of your input
data set but you can also do
same sort of things like saving images
so
yeah check that out if you're if you're
interested in learning more about that
and get reconnected here
and cool
good to go so i'll actually show an
example of a different way
to say if you just wanted to turn a
different way that kind of as a
side effect has allows you to download a
plot this kind of also ties into the
question of like you use
customized graphics you know different
packages say you wanted to let's just
run this
this is under the fancy app the first
gapminder.r i'll just run this app
if you just scroll through you can see
that it's quite a bit more
complicated uh we'll go through that
kind of
section by section here in a minute but
it's a little bit more helpful i think
just to look and see
what it actually does and then when we
get to different sections you can tie it
back to what's what's happening in the
running app
so we've got a slider we've already seen
that before in this case
it's uh filtering on year so now we're
kind of you know
now we're looking at between year you
know 1973 and 2011.
and we're selecting a country so we're
looking at just morocco
and we can you know select different
countries it's showing year versus
life's expectancy
uh and we're also showing this is you
know we've only showed plots before now
we're showing
a table and this is visualized using the
data table
package which is actually just kind of a
wrapper to the an underlying javascript
library
that again if you don't know javascript
you don't have to think about it at all
so that's the dt package
and we're doing a bit more you know
complicated things to our data set as
well
we're using this gap minder data but of
course gapmind has a lot of
you know countries other than these and
we're also doing some kind of collapsing
um
you know regions so we got north america
uh we're doing some some wrangling some
pre-processing
and in all of our other apps we've kind
of done everything within there's been
you know it's like library shiny a big
ui block
a big server block and then the last
line runs the app
if you do need to do some pre-processing
you can do in two ways you can
pre-process your data set beforehand
and then just call that data sets ready
to go
but if you need to do a little minimal
pre-processing within the app
you don't necessarily want to include
that in the server function because it
might get
called more times than it needs to be
and you know that results in your
app being a little bit slow and less
user friendly
sorry i'll try not to do that again
no words unfortunately i'm sure that i'm
behind the scenes making sure things are
going okay so sorry about that
yeah no no awesome appreciate it phil um
yeah so here we're doing some again if
you don't know d
plier don't worry about this but just
think about this you know we're just
doing some
some data wrangling we're specifying the
countries that we want to
call us west uh we're mutating creating
this
region group with the case when
statement uh you know sql it's
kind of an analogous event to that if
it's the region's in west we're calling
it west if it's in
one of these countries we're calling it
east asia et cetera
yeah dropping some missing data creating
a couple of new columns
and then we have a new data set to work
with um you know called
gap minder and then we switch into you
know our shiny stuff so we've got our
our user interface and our uh
and then down here server logic
let's run this again and get it going
um
cool so yeah we've got
our input id your input that's here and
that's going into the slider
we've got a drop drop down we've seen
those before select the input
select slider input
and we've got our main panel which we're
you know calling the output cool plots
you know you can
uh you can call this whatever you want
to but obviously if you're
building this up to something more
complex cool plot is not going to be
really descriptive when you come back to
your code later or someone else looks at
your code and tries to figure it out
but you know any string there's is going
to be
you can give it any any name that you
want
[Music]
this is new so we have our our output
we've got our plot output we've seen
that before but
the uh table that we've got down here
needs a different
output uh shiny is not going to know how
to process that is a plot because it's
not a plot image so we give it
you know it's got we have this function
dt output
and corresponding within the server
um you know we've got this chunk here
uh that's calling render plot doing
doing some filtering you know we're not
we're not redoing all of that
data wrangling that we did up above
we're taking starting with the output of
that data wrangling
and we're doing some additional
filtering so that's you know the
filtering
based on where we put these sliders um
in this case you know we've got that
input year input you can see it's
actually now a list of uh you know
length
two so the first uh first element is
going to be
that lower endpoint second element's
going to be that upper end point and
you're filtering
for years in between and then we've
taken in another country input here
we're doing that filtering and then
we're creating our plot
and we're doing a similar sort of thing
for
the uh the output and
uh instead of render plot we're doing
render dt
so we're creating this new data set
called filtered
as it's just a data frame and
where any time one of these inputs
changes
it filters the data set to just that and
then renders that
in the slot that we specified for the uh
for our table to be um
and then of course i always need this at
the end to actually run your app
um i'm gonna show one thing really
quickly
say say you're familiar with the plotly
library
and you want to turn this into instead
of a ggplot you want to make this
interactive and turn this into a plotly
graph you can actually do that really
easily without you know probably
modifying just like three or four lines
of code
so we're going to call the plotly
library
and when we go down here instead of
plot output there's a
plotley output so add a couple of lines
there
similarly with this we've got instead of
render plot we need to do render plotly
and then plotly has a function called
uh ggplotly that will convert a ggplot
object to a plotley object
and i find the simplest way to do this
is actually just to give your plot
you know save your plot as uh you know
give it a name
call it p and then
we can just now we have that same plot
same gg plot that we had before
now we're just going to turn that into a
plotly object
i think we reload this
there we go um
you can see now we've turned this into a
plotly object with everything that you
know comes with polly so we can
hover over the points um and i also
mentioned this because if you wanted
to download a copy of that plotly has
that built in
um that's probably not the official
solution for
upload download but if you just need one
plot downloaded that's also
kind of a hack for that and again like
there was only i think
maybe four or five lines of code needed
to change
to be changed there
um what time do we have
i really like to spend a little bit of
time on the last module and since um
just kind of going through all these
without
kind of you know being able to wander
around and look at everyone's
screens and help out i'm going to skip
over this exercise
but
encourage you to look at if you're yeah
want to
play around a little bit more and kind
of see test your understanding
this is a if you go ahead and run this
as is of course it's not going to run
it's got a bunch of kind of underscores
as placeholders
so if you go through and
either you know compare to the previous
one for certain certain bits
and then this will build up a more
complicated app
with adding in some more uh
some more functionality and uh encourage
you to
go through that and uh on your own time
if you're interested
so finally i'm gonna move on to
um flex dashboard
and this is kind of taking a step back a
little bit you know we started out with
our markdown
then went into shiny apps and they said
they have this structure with
a user interface and a server
and you know inputs to the unit that are
specified in the user interface when
those change
server logic is watching listening for
that
and then it reruns whatever code or
visualization that
you've got based on those inputs and
then outputs it to your uh
to your final output in your app we're
going to go back here and actually this
is just a strict our markdown document
and this kind of gets back to that
question that we had earlier about
parameterizing so this
right here we're going back to our
original fda data looking at adverse
events this is exactly the same
in fact it's almost exactly we're going
to do it pretty pretty much recreate
that our markdown in a flex dashboard
format so there's a couple of things
here you know the output
specifies flex dashboard especially
specifying the or
orientation it's going to be in columns
you specify that as rows just depending
on how you want to organize your app
this r code here is all the same your
normal
are markdown chunks
again we've seen that code before and
okay now we've got some new steps we've
got columns
with um label two headers these dashes
um and then
within that we've got these level three
headers the
you know triple hashtag it's finally got
all events
age range events by gender and
this is specifying you know columns
within our out our dashboard
and this is specifying another column
and we're going to put two
rows within that so it's kind of
building up this grid sort of layout
and if we run it or actually our
markdown we're going to knit
going back here you can see i didn't
actually put any code in here this isn't
outputting any graphs or anything so
it's all empty right now
but we've got that first column and then
that second column with two rows in it
and it's
kind of this is instead of having the
user interface you're specifying the
layout within
this flex dashboard package
you know this structure specifying
columns and rows
so that's kind of the basic skeleton for
setting it up let's
let's go to uh adverse events
and we've got pretty much the same thing
here we've added a new thing here
you know a parameter so this is
parameterized report
in this case we're specifying it for
aspirin
again our code to grab the data
and execute the query create our age
range
and now we've got that same column all
events
and column with age range and events by
gender
the same structure
uh but now we're gonna
do a little you know put some plots in
here and you know
put a little bit of you know information
on what uh what age we selected
that sort of thing so let's close
give this a moment to load
there we go so you can see that
you know our parameter that we specify
you know drug aspirin
is there we've got our uh
age range in that upper bit we specified
to use an icon in there
we've got our two plots and that's great
um kind of cool clean looking interface
um it's parameterized so say we want to
go
back and run this um day on tylenol
yeah it's it's parameterized it's going
to run that let's give it a minute
there but of course it's reproducibly
easy to like
regenerate for different drugs but it's
still obviously not as
friendly and not as interact not
interactive like a shiny app is
okay so here we go now we've got it for
tylenol
so let's go to the last example here
so adverse events shiny
we're going to take that previous
dashboard that we had and turn that
into an interactive one where instead of
having to specify
you know your drug as a parameter you
can just select it
and a quick scroll through it looks
pretty similar to what we had before
in terms of layout we've got these
columns um
you know rows specified inside and we've
got all of our um you know
gg plots to you know build up the
visualizations
uh we've got some more stuff going on up
here
i can go through all of that but you can
see that we're specifying a shiny
runtime this is gonna allow us to
embed shiny right in the dashboard
this is all the same grab our data
and now we've got this first column
which we're
formatting as a sidebar and
so you can see this is shiny um it's you
know the text you know we've seen slider
input before
text input is allows us to directly
input text
and you know this is our input id
and that's going to be our label and the
default value
seems slider but you can see missing
from this entire thing is the ui
and again flex dashboard and shiny is
taking
care of that for you in the background
and you're just specifying
your inputs here
you're creating a new data set and it's
wrapped in this reactive statement
and that reactive turns this into
from just regular code to a reactive
object that listens for changes in your
input
so in this case again we're looking at
that slider
and saying okay we're gonna whenever
either the upper lower end point changes
we're going to recreate that that age
label
and then you know same thing with male
and female
so then we have you know data set male
data set for female for
that particular age range and drug
and then going down here uh instead of
just our gg plot like we had in the
the last regular flex dashboard example
we've got
everything wrapped in render plot
and again this isn't within server logic
kind of this is all taken care of for
you under the hood you can just quickly
take whatever plot you've got
you have you've developed the
prototyping kind of
maybe add a little bit of filtering or
you know wrap it in render plot
and uh you can embed it right within
your inside your dashboard
so let's go ahead and run
run documents
and cool so this looks kind of the right
part of this ignoring that left column
looks
exactly like what we had before we've
got an age range our plots
the the main distribution
but you know bar chart for adverse
events but now
say we want to go back and look at
aspirin
hit enter and you know we got out one of
i think we looked at
intruder initially
there we go so now we've got that
interactive flexibility
built up into that that dashboard
structure
um one thing i'll quickly note on this
is this is running
as a shiny document so the you know the
flex dashboard
itself just the regular dashboard is an
html that you can
you know send to someone else they can
open it up in their browser this does
require a server that's running r
and kind of one of the uh
solutions that we briefly touched on
using like shiny apps or
io or studio connect hosting it on your
own in some in some way
so this does require a server to be host
to be running shiny
um
well looks like we've got about 10
minutes left before a heart stop
so let's see if anyone has any questions
take a look and see what we've got in
the chat
um here i've got one so uh what is a
good way or a recommended way to
test shiny apps do you use the uh the
shiny test package
oh yeah good good question um so
on one i guess there's you know shiny
apps are made of a whole
bunch of different things you've got the
stuff that's specific to shiny
and kind of how it's all packaged
together and the reactive programming
and
of course you want to test and then you
might as you build up a more complex app
you might
also just have like regular functions
that you're importing in that just do a
particular task and you want to make
sure that those stay
the same so that of course you know good
programming practices are important and
you know developing the
documenting those those functions
and you you've already heard in this
session about you know things like
oxygen and and test that
to make sure that you know you're
documenting and testing
um testing code that you previously
write you've previously written as you
you know update and make modifications
the shiny test
package is also great kind of will run
a bunch of tests on your
uh on your shiny app as it like all
integrated so that instead of having to
like spin it up have a bunch of people
different people look at it and then
someone be like oh like this drop down
menu doesn't
uh update this graph in the right way or
this isn't working or you go here and
then there and then all of a sudden it
breaks
uh it does a lot of that sort of testing
for you so i think that's
also a good uh path for testing
great thank you and then i think we have
enough time for one more question
um and it looks like carlos answered it
in the chat
but i loved his answer so let me go
ahead and ask this question as well and
carlos if you want to jump on an answer
as well you're welcome too
um but let's say so say you have a quite
expensive setup function
is it better to interactively if when
each interaction is triggered
or put it externally outside of
everything i imagine a situation in
which you could have many of them so
putting
every outside putting everyone outside
could be slowing down the startup
but the navigation will be smooth as the
opposite of making the startup quick but
slowing down the usability
in that situation what would be a good
strategy to refactor the app
hi uh can you guys hear me uh yep
yeah i can hear you so it's a very
interesting question and
when i was reading through it i was
thinking how would i do that so
it um for for small applications like
the ones that
mike has been showing i don't think
there would be any issue
of uh having the functionality
of the app inside of the application or
outside the application
um as practice i normally tend to uh
build the do the processes before the
data goes into the app
and that is applied to any other kind of
visualization work that you do like if
you're using
django and javascript then you would do
it between all of the preprocessing on
the
database of django and then you will be
putting
the outputs directly into a chart.js
library or something like that
or the same with power bi or tableau all
of
all of these tools you would be using
the database to do the pre-processing
and then those other tools would be
receiving the clean data
so for this question to answer this
question
if the application is too complex then i
would recommend to use a database
to do all of that work before the data
goes out
yeah that's awesome thing yeah thanks
carlos um
yeah exactly that's putting i think kind
of as a general
rule of thumb putting as little as
possible in the server logic because
that's what's going to get triggered
interactively and then doing as much as
possible
before you even go into the app so yeah
any
wrangling processing modeling that can
be done before
that can be done you know beforehand and
then you just put in the clean pull in
the clean data set
that's uh we'll speed it up as well
yep and i um i just shared a link with
um samantha about joe chang's keynote
at the 2019 r studio conference where he
talks a lot about
uh scaling shiny and managing it in
production and so it's a
it's a really good talk and it also
talks about the things that carlos just
mentioned so
awesome yeah yeah while we're on that
topic i'll
show this as well uh are you able to see
my
screen here the i've got some like a
resources slide
yes and then i also share the um
talk joe chang's talk youtube in the
chat for everyone
okay awesome um yeah like i briefly
showed this mastering shiny
uh book which is great intro and kind of
um
getting a broad overview you're really
going into those issues like trying to
like do stuff
at production grade this book i'm
actually not sure if that's been
fully released yeah it might still be a
work in progress it's also
a really good source for those those
sorts of problems
wonderful thank you so much mike and uh
thank you to everyone here
um let me quickly wrap this up for
everyone
um
[Music]
all right so thank you again to everyone
that has joined us today
for the uh rstudio global our in pharma
x session brought to you today by
prokagya
um if you haven't registered for our
studio global which i hope most of you
have
go ahead and do that now our 24-hour
marathon of events kicks off on thursday
for everyone that did join us today
materials will be available
on materials and videos for sessions
that we can share will be made available
for you via email and online
following our studio global conference
i've
saved most of the questions here so if
there's any that we are able to follow
up on we can do that through our studio
community
and once again thank you to all of our
wonderful presenters today
for sharing all of their industry
expertise thank you everyone and we'll
see you at global